[Music]
glenn close
shaking her butt to dub butt at the 2021
oscars safe to call the moment a show
saver
and one that could forever go down in
meme history
but let's rewind glenn showed up to the
2021 oscars in this
stunning blue gown she was nominated for
best actress in a supporting role for
her work in hillbilly elegy
it was her eighth nomination she lost
out to minari star
zhoo zhong yung but won the audience
over with her knowledge of debut's
history
during a break in the show in between
categories
when quest love and lil rel decided to
play a musical guessing game
quest love just play let me see here we
[Music]
go
[Music]
was wait a second it was a classic song
by the great washington dc go go band eu
so yeah and shout outs to sugar bear and
the whole the backyard band and the
whole dmv
and that's not all glenn appears to love
and know more about the song than most
people
ever i remember this so spike lee
you know had it written for his
brilliant movie
school days and um my friends
at the oscars missed it and
it wasn't nominated so it couldn't have
won
and because of her extensive knowledge
well how could she
not know the dance
so despite the oscar loss it was truly
an epic night for glenn
who by the way also revealed she rubbed
cbd cream on her feet
before the show started